you know what is up everybody it is
prestigio man luigi here with another
Borderlands the pre-sequel legendary
guide today I'm going to be showing you
how to get the support relay to support
relay is a Hyperion made legendary oz
kit or OH - kit it's read text read
multi core life support and for every
person that has a support relay it
improves Oh - or oszi oz capacity by 25
and the consumption rate by 20% so if
you have a full party of four all
wearing support relays you're going to
get some pretty good odds capacity and a
consumption rate slowing so it also does
provide extra gun damage for each unit
of o2 that you have in your capacity you
can see at level 50 it's giving you a
cool 0.16 percent increase and with the
oz capacity being at 168 that becomes
around 25% increased gun damage when you
have a full oz capacity which is a
significant amount of gun damage it can
come in any elements I've found Arctic
and also I had to redo the mission I've
gotten it electric however wasn't called
electric is called like shock probably
and it has a pretty good slant damage of
35k it I believe it's a it's a pretty
alright oz kit I personally like the 3d
d1e is the best oz get in the game in my
opinion that's what I really like
however this is a pretty good one I
haven't paired I haven't had it with
other people and if you have it with
other people that gives you a lot more
odds capacity which would give you even
more than the 25% gun damage since say
you have four people
that's another hundred that's 268 it's a
270 oz capacity and about since 16% of
that is increased to your gun damage
percentage so that's pretty great
I think it's an alright oz kits like
it's pretty easy to get since you get it
off of a quest you just do the quest and
then you get it so I think it's
guaranteed to get so with being a
guaranteed quest item I think it's
pretty good and that's about it for the
details on the Oz kit I'm going to show
you how to get it the quest the quest
you get a
and kind of little tips to how to do
that quest better so enjoy you will be
finding this quest in Triton flats near
around near the top of the map I would
say you can exit Concordia from Moxie's
back tour exit and you will be put right
near where you're going to get it so
you're going to go over to this message
board and get the message mission
message mission to Arms you're gonna get
an old Russian stereotypically Russian
Communist taked
Papa crust who's going to talk to you
and he's gonna tell you to go to the
weapons drop and once you get there he's
going to tell you that you need to get
fifty common weapons and donate them to
the cause so you see this is the mailbox
you're gonna have to get twenty common
weapons I have a pretty good strategy
for doing this otherwise just play
through the game and get it your get get
them as you play through the game that
is one way of doing it
however this is another way I would see
just waiting to level 50 and to do this
and once you level 50 you're not going
to be playing through the game to get
Commons so here's a way to do it so
you're gonna head to Virago solitude and
you go ahead pass through all this
you're gonna want to go to where you
fight RK 5 since and Oh make sure you're
in normal mode you could have seen I
change the normal mode make sure your
normal mode you're gonna get to the
outfall compensation gonna go see RK 5
kill them really fast cuz he's level 26
and your level 50 again do not do this
mission if you're not little 50 because
it takes away too much time and it's not
worth it
so when to kill RK 5 you're gonna pick
up all these good common weapons that he
drops good for this mission I guess
since he does drop a ton of common
weapons and you can save and quit and
spawn back right here and kill him again
so it's really easy way to farm you're
only gonna have to make that Virago
solitude run once since now you're going
to exit your game and go back into true
vault hunter mode and deposit your
weapons and that's how you're gonna be
grinding for these 50 weapons every time
you want them you want more common
weapons just go back into normal mode
and you'll be you'll spawn right next RK
5 however every time you get 10 common
weapons in the cache a in the little
vault mailbox he's gonna send you on a
mission to help out the cause and the
PLA members People's Liberation are
I believe it is so that'll rain from
getting boxes to handling disputes among
other members to killing people at their
base killing uh enemies of the cause I
guess you would call it at their base so
every time you get ten extra you're
gonna have to do one of these missions
and the missions are always set in stone
they're always the same thing so don't
worry about it being too bad since it's
there they're pretty easy missions it
just mainly has to do with killing
people and yeah killing people is just a
general theme into these missions is the
general theme Borderlands so it makes
sense so you'll get one at ten you'll
get one at twenty to go on a thirty and
you'll get one at forty so you're going
to just run through all of these you can
see I'm on the one where you have to go
kill other people and get their guns
which was the same as the previous
mission except previous mission they
were all on cars and now they're just
all on a base right before you get to
red-bellied that's the area they're at
so you can see I'm just going through
all of it it is pretty quick I'm level
50 and I do have some pretty good gear
but I think even if you don't have super
good gear you'll still be able to do a
pretty good job of this here you can see
me I'm going to investigate the disputes
you choose a guy and then you have to
defend in from the other two guys which
and you have to kill because border
lines you got to kill the guys so that's
kind of that's gonna be how you get it
it's pretty once you know how to get
common weapons fast which through the
rk5 method the rest of this goes pretty
quickly and the last mission you get you
just defend the armed spot which is the
place you keep dropping arms in you're
just going to defend that from a bunch
of enemies if you kill all the enemies
you can see here I'm about to put in the
weapons and I'm gonna have to defend it
so once you defend it then you put your
last batch of Commons in and you'll be
given you'll finish the 50 which is
you'll finish all the work to do with
the two arms mission and you're gonna
have to head to Concordia Watch pop
crust give you a good old speech about
arts know more about liberation and then
it's art that's the kicker on this and
you head over to the mission board and
you'll get yourself your support relay
so hope you guys have enjoyed this video
make sure you check out my other LED
Neri guides if you are into this since I
do have a good amount of other legendary
guides and I will be continuing to make
more so if you want to see more keep
looking on my channel that's basically
it I hope you guys enjoy this video and
I'll see you later peace